[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
ramsy show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America Ken Coleman
Ramsey personality number one
bestselling author of the book paycheck
to purpose and host of the Ken Coleman
show talking about your job your career
how you make money and finding work you
love and that you make more money than
you ever made in your life he's my
co-host today so if you want to talk
about any of that you jump in we will
phone number Isle
5225 that's
5225 Robert Is With Us in Alberta Canada
hi Robert how are you I'm doing well how
about your better than I deserve what's
up all right I'm looking to buy my first
house with my wife we have about 150,000
saved and my in-laws are being generous
and letting us about 100,000 to help
with a down payment that's enough for us
to get a decent town home in our area um
and that way we would only owe family
but at the that payback rate they want
with my in-laws um we have room for
about $100,000 mortgage while staying
below your recommended 25% limit we're
wondering if it's a good idea to take
the mortgage if as a result we might
stay in the home longer or am I just
trying to talk myself into uh
debt well it sounds like all of these
decisions are made except the last one
so I'm not sure how much I'll be able to
influence
this um because you all aren't going to
like my answer I would recommend you
don't take out a loan with your
in-laws oh really yeah the borrower is
slave to the lender and when you owe
your father-in-law money Thanksgiving
dinner tastes
different yeah all right uh this is how
families end up not speaking to each
other and it's a it's a uh they they are
not necessarily um they probably aren't
because you didn't bring it up they're
probably very kind not controlling
people um that will all change the first
time you miss a
payment and suddenly where you went on
vacation the brand of the kids closed
matters MH they're looking at every
every decision you make with money as to
whether they get paid or not they can't
keep from doing it because they're human
beings now how bitter they are angry
they are or toxic they are in response
to those situations are could be
different depending on how wonderful
people they are but it doesn't matter
you're going to feel different your wife
won't feel as much of it as you will but
you're going to feel it and uh so that's
my speech I would not do that I would
highly recommend I will never loan my
children money ever now I may give them
some money if I've got some extra money
to do something like you're talking
about I would make that a gift
personally uh but that's pretty bold to
ask for that on your part but uh but but
uh U anyway all all of that to say yeah
I I would buy a house that your down
payment plus your mortgage that you can
afford would purchase not an in-law loan
but again I Robert I have no expectation
for you to follow that advice because
you guys have already kind of discussed
it you're comfortable with it you threw
it out there like is like I'm picking
out a shirt you didn't think about it at
all yeah and I I hope people don't miss
what you just said because the dynamic
changes when you start talking about
your in-laws doing anything for you I
remember before we got married um we
were doing uh some counseling we came
back from a counseling uh session pre
premarital and Stacy's father uh met us
at the door and and he he had been
working through her finances before she
came into our marriage and she had not a
huge amount may have been about $15,000
as the student loans and I was ready to
take it on we had already talked through
it I had no student loan debt at the
time all that to say he surprised us and
he said I'm going to we want to give you
this we want to start you all off you
know and it was just really really
wonderful very nice but even though it
was a gift Dave it was still in the back
of my mind still touches the pr button
yes and that's what I'm glad you called
it that because I it still felt like and
it it wasn't my debt but it was going to
be our debt yeah and it was in the back
of my mind like I owed him something and
it didn't turn into any kind of tension
cuz I got it it was a gift it was a
complete gift but if you had to pay that
payment oh that would have really been
was already jacking with me just because
it was a gift and I think that's what I
want people to hear why would you want
to do that exactly exactly I I I have
trouble um just as a general category in
my life I'm not as bad at it now
receiving gifts yeah I always have I'm a
giver I'm generous but uh but I I'm not
real good at receiving I'm not even good
if you pick up the tab at dinner I just
I always want to be the guy where do you
where do you think that comes from I
don't know Pride probably but I I I am
much more able to do that than I am the
only time I've ever gotten into this
situation personally is Sharon's dad is
an absolute Saint he is an incredible
easy to get along with guy on the planet
never said an unkind word since and 40
years we I've been married to her I've
never heard him say anything unkind
except the opposite political party
right occasionally he say something but
but um and he's wrong about that but the
um but he's he's a wonderful guy and
when we went bankrupt he loaned us a
little money to get the house caught up
and do some things and um man he never
said a single thing it was all paid back
but my stomach yeah was not the same
until I got that that cleared yeah it
just it you talk about you like you said
jacked with you messed with you and the
old joke is anybody you loan money to it
changes the relationship it does it
changes a friendship it changes your
roommate it changes your you loan money
to your girlfriend oh that screwed that
whole thing up you know uh anybody you
when you loan money to someone you
change it from whatever this mother
father uh relationship to you know to to
master slave y friend to Master Slave
and the old joke is if you loan your
brother-in-law $100 and he he never pays
it back but he never speaks to you again
is it worth
it you know so you know but that that's
you know that's the kind of thing you
can get into now again I will say
clearly the way Robert presented that
I'm pretty sure his in-laws are not
toxic people that's right I think
they're probably for like Sharon's dad
but it will change well you nailed it
it'll weigh on him so let's say he's
talking about the vacation and maybe
they don't even look at him sideways but
he wonders did I see a look did I you
you start start manifesting things to
your point your father-in-law never said
anything negative never has but it was
in your head so that's where I came up
with the saying I think you're right
Thanksgiving dinner doesn't taste the
same cuz I experienced that you did I'm
sitting at the Thanksgiving table
thinking about this and he's not
thinking about it yeah it didn't bother
him a bit Yeah but um but because he's a
kind Master yeah and I was a rebellious
slave that's right that's right well you
know it reminds us of our good friend
Henry Cloud you know talking about
boundaries that's a boundary that I
think you're right it should always be
set don't take a loan from family
members F if you want to if you want to
help your children and you have the
extra money and you want to give them
some money no strings attached no
controlling that's fine but no
co-signing for them for God's sakes
don't co-sign for people
and no loaning don't loan them money you
will you will mess up what should have
been a good pure thing this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's it's a membership based
nonprofit Ministry where hundreds of
thousands of Christians share funds to
pay for and pray for each other's
medical bills for over 40 years chm has
helped families living across all 50
states so see if chm could be right for
your family check out more today at
chministries.org
[Music]
budget
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
George is with us George is in boisey
Idaho hi George how are
you uh been better how about you guys
better than I deserve what's
up so I have a kind of a weird
question um I'm wondering if I should
get a job and yeah
SW I was gonna say the same I'm sorry it
was under underand pitch well go
ahead so it's kind of a very very unique
situation I applied to a government job
back in January of this
year and I got a start date for last
Monday long story short the week my last
week at my previous sh that I quit the
Wednesday HR calls me and says hey we
gave you a start date on Monday but it
actually isn't gonna
happen um and we don't know how long
it's going to be because it's a
government job so it has some security
clearance and she was saying that it can
be anywhere from a month to a couple to
a year that we can get you approved and
I asked her okay well can I get a job in
the meantime and she said if you do that
then it's going to delay your clearance
and could push you back right now
so my wife and I luckily we have no debt
we have three months of emergency fund
but we're just in a situation where
we're not sure what to do in regards to
it get a job if get a job uh you don't
let some woman from the government give
you that kind of nonsensical answer like
you're supposed to put your life on hold
and I don't want you to touch that
emergency fund either not when you are
able I don't want you to take the
government job yeah well that's the
other that's the red flag I hadn't
gotten to yet but that's what a joke
like would you want to work for somebody
who treats you that
way no not at all then walk get back on
the horse get back in there don't touch
the emergency what was that job going to
pay it was going to pay about two and a
half times my salary for where I was
currently at what is
that uh facil uh government facility
engineer no how much is it going to pay
the job you're not going to take with
the government oh sorry about 110,000
okay wonderful and you said you're doing
what Facilities
Management uh facility engineer facility
engineer for for some kind of a
classified um
facility correct yes okay it's for the
the Navy okay all right that's why the
security clearance all right well I
suspect if the government is willing to
pay you 110 you're probably worth more
than that a lot more somewhere else in
the same field and so I would start
looking for a job like four months ago
but yes but today you'll
do and okay wouldn't you can I mean yeah
and here's the deal I don't want you to
just get a job why don't you go get a
job making 130 in that field yeah and
and listen uh my version of waiting
always involves acting and so I I would
call their Bluff on that that that's
going to mess with your security
clearance makes zero sense to me and uh
as Dave said he's right I would bet you
that you have a a chance at 2 to 3x long
term uh certainly possible in the short
term as an engineer go do that work
don't wait and if they come calling then
you can answer yeah I don't know what
the percentage is but just my walking
around sense tells me that there are
almost no government positions that pay
as much as their mainstream counterpart
I would agree with that I'd be shocked
if in accounting if you're in accounting
and you work for the government you make
70% 80% of what you would make in the
open market as an accountant or less and
but I have security yeah well guess what
they can't seem to get the security
clearance going so yeah I I I mean
there's a few things in the government
that are very specialized that actually
could pay more but there's so few and
far between that they're not even part
of The Stereotype generally speaking
government employees are not not paid
what that's correct their counterparts
are in the marketpl Dave I don't know if
you picked up on this but my gut I got a
little cynicism that that feels like a
really polite brush off is what that
it's like an excuse for a brush off it
makes no sense to me it's not adding up
doesn't pass the smell test I would
absolutely walk you know if it was
private sector I'd believe you you I
think this is just straight up
incompetence could be could be a week to
a year it seems like a very yeah I mean
we got this narrowed
down I just it to be absurd to say that
to somebody but but there you go well I
mean again it's not they don't think
anything about it that that's again
that's do you want to be in like you
said do you want to work for somebody
like that but do you want to be in that
kind of an environment where that's how
they're going to treat people you know
is uh like a sloth you know it's like
we're going to move very yeah like what
is he supposed
to that's right Jenna is in Rockford
Illinois hey Jenna welcome to the Ramsey
Show Hi how are you better than I
deserve what's up good thanks for taking
my call sure um so my husband and I were
debt-free except for our mortgage um we'
paid off cars we paid off student loans
we've been pretty aggressive on paying
off our mortgage as well uh trying to
hit for double the amount each month
where to go um we yeah thank you we have
about 59,000 left to pay on our mortgage
but recently a piece of property popped
up on our radar that were extremely
interested in um it's a major fixer uper
though so it will take a lot of money to
invest in I'm I'm probably thinking
$100,000 just to get it up to code um is
it a good idea in this market right now
to purchase this or should we just stay
where we're at comfortably paying off
our current
mortgage how long y'all been
married uh we've been married for 12
years what's the uh purchase price of
the fixer upper
um right now it's listed for about
$320,000 and it's so bad that it needs
$100,000 just to get it
habitable yeah and that's why we're
talking the price down just to get it
you know figured out but um we currently
own a house that in this current market
is selling for about 290 to 300,000
itself okay the other side is we also
have four children and so we have a very
comfortable lifestyle the stay at home
mom um so we're extremely comfortable
and I'm wondering if this is just going
to be too much to take on especially in
this parket it is it is a lot to take on
and let me tell you how it becomes a
disaster okay um it becomes a disaster
if a you pay too much and B you don't do
a really good job of project managing
this
renovation because people that have
never done this before which is you uh
have a tendency to end up doubling what
they thought they were going to spend
and tripling the
time it was going to take for you to do
the
renovation and so you cannot allow that
to happen the second thing that will
destroy your life with that many kids in
a 12-year marriage is to try to live in
the house while you're renovating
it that will
really take away any fun that this deal
had so that's when you end up with a
dream that becomes a nightmare so the
way I always test myself is am I do I
want this so badly that I'm willing to
be uncomfortable for a little while
here's what uncomfortable for a little
while in your case looks like um you get
three detailed indepth bids on what it
takes to fix this
property okay including a schedule a
budget and a schedule from the
contractor and you check out their
references and you look at that and you
say okay this is what it's going to take
cuz you have to manage contractors and
you have to manage your own expectations
you can't make this crap up as you go so
you need to start the project with the
end in mind you need to have every
detail combed out every tangle combed
out of the hair every detail laid out
before you even close on the
property okay we're going to say Ready
set go we've got all the dominoes lined
up perfectly we're going to push the IND
Domino and then I'm going to hold the
contractor to the schedule and to the
budget and we're going to kick these
doors down and get this done okay like
Fast number one number two you got to
sell your house and move into a
rental cuz you need the money have both
cuz you need the money we actually have
both um parents living here that have
plenty of space for us to all okay well
sell your house and move somewhere and
put the cash in your pocket to do this
work with so you're doing it with cash
and you're going to get a little bit a
little bit of a mortgage but you're
doing it with cash and then the third
thing is you have to get an appraisal of
the property as if it was renovated and
then deduct all of the renovation costs
from the current asking or from that
price to where it is below the current
asking price I suspect plus $50,000 for
your
trouble and I don't think you're going
to be able to get all three of these
things to work in your comfort zone so I
don't think you're going to buy this
it's a it's a pain in the
butt
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
church hill mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the church hill mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Church Hill
has bumped up their seller guarantee to
$10,000 giving your offer the best
chance of being accept accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is
my co-host today if you haven't heard
we're going to be in
Chicagoland the northern section there
we'll be at the Willer Creek Church
doing our smart conference event
September 15th and 16th and when I say
we I mean all the Wiis Dave Rachel Cruz
John deloney Jade washaw George the new
dad camel and Ken Coleman we're going to
be talking about mental health careers
money oh just how to get your life
together how to win in every area of
your life the smart conference is Friday
night all day Saturday September 15 and
16 dedicated a weekend to be focused and
smart and uh dial in on your goals with
your money your mental health your
career your relationships your
motivation and information and
inspiration will all be there smart
conference weekend is our biggest event
of the Year tickets are starting at $99
there are limited ticket upgrades
available that include some meet and
greets you ought to check all of those
out go to ramsy solutions.com
events go to smart conference September
15 and 16 just a couple of weeks away
we'll be there in the land of Chicago so
looking forward to having you guys
Jeremy Is With Us in Atlanta hi Jeremy
welcome to the ramsy show hey thanks a
lot Dave thanks for having me sure
what's up um so uh long story short I'm
afraid to go into a full-time career in
fear that I'll make the wrong decision
okay what's the basing the what's the
fear based on past experience or just
something
unknown um probably a little bit of both
I was in Ministry for 12 years and um
steep back uh in end of 2020 when we
moved and then um just been working odd
jobs ever since um I started my own
company just doing long hair and
pressure washing but it's not really
what what I want to do other than just
making some side money is there an
opportunity right now in front of you
that you've got a chance to take and
you're starting to Waffle or what or is
this just considering the idea of now
going back into something
else I think considering my wife works
for a company and she's kind of
presented me a couple Ro roles up there
um that are in Ministry um which is what
I was obviously working before and just
got I'm just afraid you know so what did
you drop out what cost you to to to dial
back and drop out was it burn burnout
was it a toxic situation what there's
something there that you're afraid of
repeating and the way you're saying it
tells me that you've acknowledged that
maybe you didn't uh monitor things maybe
you made some poor decisions tell me
what specifically you're worried about
repeating H I guess so I got out we
moved um once we adopted our son got
closer back to family uh and um I just
don't want to
I guess with when the pandemic happened
I took on a lot of extra roles I hadn't
anticipated at the church and um the
church I serve at now I really like
serving with them and I'm just fearful
that I don't know if I'm supposed to go
back into Ministry or just do something
completely different I did the get clear
assessment on Sunday yeah um just to try
to kind of yeah tell us give me the
results um so the
says I was created to use my talents of
imagination compassion and communication
to perform my passions of leading
performing and finishing to accomplish
my mission of influence all right well
let me tell you what that means okay
when you see that missional result the
results that motivate you that's
intrinsic they just get you out of bed
that's a people situation and when you
talk about
imagination uh and the compassion piece
again that's ideas and people it's just
screaming out that's what you were
created to do and so whether it's in
Ministry or it's in the it's in the
corporate world as long as you are
seeing that purpose statement that you
just read briefly to us that is a job
description high level and so you've got
to be using those tools to be doing work
that you really love and that performing
piece there's a pressure to that that
performing doesn't mean I've got to be
an actor or a singer it is I need
pressure to deliver and I'm going to
tell you you you need to be in the
business and I'm talking the work of
delivering people results you see your
work creating influence or
transformation does that square with
your heart sounds like a Ministry yeah
yeah yeah exactly and and the job that
my wife presented to me is a kind of a
business and Ministry it's kind of two
in one well look at the job description
how how old are you 37 how long did you
work in
Ministry uh for 12 years who hurt you
yeah
um answer it I think no you
know you know probably my the first
Pastor I worked for yeah so it's not
what you were doing it's that you were
doing it with the wrong people yeah and
you lost some of your confidence when
you got your ke teeth kicked
in which is by the way why you said yes
to so many things at the second church
or however along the journey that was
not being able to say no is a function
of fear I'm afraid what people will say
I'm afraid what will happen to me if I
put a boundary up and it's also a
function of not having priorities clear
priorities I say yes to these things and
it makes it easier for me to say no to
others you sound like a very sweet guy
who loves people and likes to lift and
help people who's hiding from a a toxic
situation behind a pressure washing wand
and your wife is calling you
out that's that's absolutely correct
that's absolutely
spoton but here's the deal you don't
need our permission uh what you need to
do is decide can I do ministry in a non-
Ministry job and I want to can you do
ministry in a Ministry situation that's
not toxic and learn to say no right and
learn to go look you don't talk to me
that way I'll go back to the pressure
warer screw this that's right you know I
mean just walk away have a necessary
ending if you get into a bad situation
what you've got to believe in again is
your ability ability and strength to
walk away or stand up and put your hand
out and say boundary time right and when
you believe in you enough to protect you
from crap happening to you again you'll
step back in and do what God's called
you to do my man cuz you're you I got a
feeling you are an
incredible uh person on a platform I got
a feeling you've got some it Factor uh
but but I even your voice tone is
telling me that something's scaring you
yeah and um I just I want to I want to
speak courage over you my man let me
tell I want speak you know you need to
be encouraged let's speak over speak
some courage into this because you need
to go be what God called you to do and
not let these stupid butt human beings
that are out there keep you from doing
it Jeremy here's my encouragement to you
your
fear of fading away needs to be far
greater than your fear of getting back
in the game you hear me CU you're fading
away you know it and I Know It wife
knows it and you know this my friend
you've been called and you better do it
you better listen to that voice and I I
would be terrified of fading away and
watching my soul seep out of my body
while I'm power washing I wonder if
Jonah had a pressure
washer I will tell you now a pressure
washer is tremendous therapy I did it
the other day got B cut on my ankle cuz
I shot myself in the foot withle thing I
love it I love it it's pressure great
mindless place to hide and I cuz you
feel like you're accomplishing something
it's so I cleaned the dock and it didn't
even need to be cleaned it was so much
fun I did my front porch the other day
and I was so proud of myself yeah Jeremy
listen there's so much potential inside
you and everyone's seeing it and you
know it's down in there but the fear of
uh whatever happened before happening
again is is the thing that's sounds to
me like that's that you're real quick
Dave I want you to go get it man I want
you to go get it yeah hey Jeremy I'm
okay with you taking maybe this gig to
get you it's a bridge let's get some
momentum back while we're picking the
next Ministry position get some get some
reps in where you ride the bike again
without the training whe I agree it
doesn't have to be right back into
Ministry is the point uh but but let's
let's move forward let's get out of what
you're doing now let's get back in the
game get that spine straight chin up
looking forward excited about the future
not stuck in the past yeah let me tell
you that people
said and did things during
Co that were the most fear-based anger
based things I've seen in my entire 63
years on the planet and so you cannot
make any decisions even about that
person that was out of control and toxic
during Co because they were so freaked
out they were so angry they were so
scared that they couldn't even they they
lost their dadgum minds some of y'all
have forgotten that but that really
happened and the result is scars on
other people this is the ramsy
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or take takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40% off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more
info
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America it's a free call at
5225 Victoria is in Atlanta Georgia hi
Victoria how are you hi I'm doing good
good what's up so essentially this past
may I graduated college at 20 and now
I'm in a PhD program and my parents were
very generous and they said all of the
money you earned in scholarships were
going to give to you at the end of your
graduation as long as you get good
grades and you graduate uh which ended
up being
$100,000 Wow way it go so what are you
getting your PhD in aerospace
engineering very nice what do you plan
to do with that uh I hope to work on
future human space travel so what do
space stations after the International
Space Station look like wow I don't know
much about that space in terms of the
career side of it why does that require
a
PhD um yeah so I'm really interested in
a lot of the like systems engineering
work and a lot of Advanced Materials and
advanced manufacturing work how long
will it take you to get the
PHD yeah so it's probably going to be
about five years why most don't take
that
long because the program I'm in they
give us they pay our tuition and they
give us a stien oh you're working yes oh
my life just changed she's getting paid
to get this PhD yes I am getting paid to
get now I now I'm going with the five
years how much do you make um I make
2,500 a month um so not much but you
know a
stipend okay and that's going to take
you 5 years I'm now now I'm not as
excited as I was a minute ago I was I
thought thought we had like a real job
you've got a you've got an intern job
okay yes let's let's answer Dave's
question Victoria why does this PhD I
know you're interested in it but does it
set you up to do the thing you want to
do to the point that if you don't get it
you're not qualified to do it that's
what we're trying to get at um it is
possible I could do it without it but it
would be a lot harder um I would at
minimum likely need a master's and the
PHD program I'm in I can Masters out of
which I am considering okay um good okay
yeah yeah I I I would like for you to Ms
out and get the big girl job and then
work on your PhD making while you're
making 200 a year yeah yeah that's kind
of what I'm thinking but I'm just I I
don't know what I'm talking about it's
my problem okay because I don't know
enough about your space but that just I
I I worry about being overeducated and
underpaid for
anyone yes that is a big fear of mine
and so overall though you've got an
incredible brain obviously and you're
obviously good at using it
congratulations and um I feel safer
already from on my Rocket Ride and um
yes that's not going to occur but the uh
uh so what what's your what are you
gonna do with
100,000 that's what I'm calling you for
I'm really not sure I I've kept my
budget pretty low and I'm living within
my means on that stipend I'm just not
putting anything into savings and so my
thoughts are like do I just throw that
100K and like a 5% High interest savings
or yes is that all I do yes for right
now until we get the next steps on the
career
going because I want to make sure you uh
get all the Educational Tools in your
belt to get the big girl career
going yeah and that 100,000 is your
insurance policy right now you got a
system that'll do it um but you may M's
out and take a job and then you may want
to invest that more aggressively at that
point or someday you might get married
and use it towards a house or something
like that uh all of that or you might
just be single and use it towards the
house either one's fine with me I don't
care but the um today you don't need to
do any of that it's it's just going to
be sitting there in a safe parking lot
making a little bit of money right now
uh and not getting damaged it's a
protected parking lot which is what
you're describing that's what I would do
because it's not going to change your
life today what's changing your life
today is you uh getting these tools in
your
belt that's my thoughts yeah I just
wanted to make sure it seems like I got
given this great gift and do I just like
lock it away for the next couple years
yeah for a couple years but not for 20
yeah for two for two when would you get
out of the master's program is that a
two-year deal a year and a half yeah I I
want to make sure you understand what
we're trying to do is Fast Forward all
of all of this financial opportunity
that you're going to be really presented
with get the Masters get a great gig to
your ability and your brightness someone
is going to pay for your PhD and you do
that as you go and now you're earning a
lot of money you have zero debt now the
100,000 comes into play as we invest
take care of those life issues that is a
beautiful plan as opposed to not making
any money for five years at a $2,500
stiping that's about 30 that's 30 Grand
in stien and that really holds you back
and I hav't ever asked Dr John delone
about this he's the only person around
here that's got two phds that I'm aware
of but um to me um I'm Mr experienced
guy more than I mean I've gotten a lot
of my knowledge that way right um and
you know in the open market reading and
you know taking courses and things but
not um formal academic at that level um
to me getting your PhD while having some
life experience would probably put color
on the PHD that is different than doing
it in a vacuum in an academic vacuum um
like for instance I met a a pastor
earlier in the summer we were traveling
and got to spend some time with him and
he was at the end of his career he was
retiring and he had just finished his
PhD and um he started telling me the
subject of it I was enthralled we we
ended up getting this dissertation out
and reading through it it was really but
it was a the PHD was not a uh it was not
a career advancement thing it was a a
you know it was almost a the
dissertation on his life was on his PhD
almost and and it was beautiful it was
absolutely the color was dep deep on it
though very vibrant and so it was a
valuable valuable process and so uh uh
not in he'll never make the money that's
not what I mean right but uh cuz he's
retiring as a pastor and his you know
his PhD was in Divinity so you know uh
doit Divinity but the uh oh my gosh yeah
that that in this case that might you
know while you're working in a rocket
company working on the problems you want
to work on with your Masters working on
your PhD it's going to change flavor of
the PHD that's what I'm saying without
question and she's right I don't again I
don't know much about Aerospace but a
lot of your astronauts she wasn't saying
she's going to necessarily be an
astronaut but the PHD is probably common
place but she doesn't have to have it at
20 she doesn't have to have it at 25 and
and so she'll get there and so that's
why we gave that advice it will probably
come in very very handy to that level of
work but doesn't have to be gotten right
away and in return Dave she's going to
be a millionaire she's going to be a
million millionaire in her 30s if she if
she she invests well she has no debt
she's clearly bright she's going to have
all kinds of opportunities living on
less than she makes ready she's living
on the stien so this is a bright person
here who who's got a bright future so we
want to maximize that for Victoria so
it's a good time with the student loan
stuff coming up to remind you guys you
know your student loans the interest
starts back uh this coming Friday yes
and the payments start back a month
later October one uh it's a good time to
remind every everyone out there that um
you have to be smart about
education that's right spending $250,000
to get a master's
degree in sociology so you can make
$38,000 a year with the state as a
caseworker is dumb that's right so don't
be dumb about education is that isn't
that a great Paradox how dumb we are
about education yeah and um you know
it's very sad and we've got now uh you
know 40 million people that have
payments that are du right now that's
correct and some of them got useless
degrees in useless fields from useless
universities uh and but that but and
then people say Well they're all useless
no they're not all useless some some of
these degrees are fabulous very useful
um yeah it's amazing very amazing good
times folks this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsey show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world to get
your daily dose of advice on life and
money check out all of our shows from
the Ramsey Network wherever you listen
to
[Music]
podcasts
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
ramsy show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Ken Coleman
Ramsey personality number one
bestselling author of the book paycheck
to purpose and uh host of the Ken
Coleman show where he talks about your
job your career you making money doing
something you love and a lot of it a lot
of what you love and a lot of money he's
here to help the phone number Isle
88255 225 Amanda is with us she is in
Gulfport Mississippi hi Amanda welcome
to the Ramsey Show hey all thank you for
taking my call sure what's
up okay my husband and I we are 34 and
have three kids we have about 70,000 in
debt and we're starting baby step two so
I'm trying to figure out you know what
we can leverage to get this paid off
okay the question was we have a Roth IRA
worth um $20,000 that we opened about
six years ago my husband open it through
Fidelity I think I don't know before
Dave Ramy um anyways what would be the
consequences of us cashing that out
is that something you recommend or never
recommend that no you're taxed you had a
10% penalty and you're tax at your tax
rate on the amount of growth in the case
of a Roth that's there so and I suspect
most of that is growth actually um so
yeah you're G it's like borrowing money
at 30 or 40% interest so we would never
do that no so that's that's actually not
a shortcut it's a shortcut but it's a
shortcut that cost you so much it's not
worth it so um that's not the plan so
what's your household
income um we gross about 120,000 a year
cool how much of the 70 is your car
payment um I own my vehicle my husband's
2022 truck is worth 3,000 I 30,000 so he
has about a $600 note yeah and so
there's 30,000 owed on the
truck yes okay all right there's your
shortcut if you want one uhhuh okay
I think she may have flooed that idea
once before breathe now I've already
thrown that out there how did he
respond well it's a new to him truck
this was in our you know our stupid days
and about a year ago we did
this I know how did he respond I think I
know but I'm just curious how did he
respond well this this was a present for
getting his Masters and getting a big
boy job and so typical middle class
stupid that's what we did um he how did
he respond to selling it as an idea very
he does not like it we knew that okay
okay that's fine yeah so here's the
thing here's the thing my a great guy
that I used to listen to when I was a
Youngster one of the fathers of
motivation and success literature is a
guy named Earl Nightingale he since
passed away and he used to say that when
we have a goal the things we're willing
to do to hit the goal are not what's as
are not as important as the things we
are willing to give up to hit the goal
so I'm qu you on that yeah you can be
willing to do a lot of things to hit a
goal um you know I'm willing to work out
I'm willing to run in order to lose
weight but I'm not willing to give up
chocolate cake you know and so that
that's the hard part of the goal now it
doesn't mean you can't ever hit the goal
it just makes it more difficult to hit
the goal so if the goal is owning a
truck that goal is competing with the
goal of being debt
free okay and same thing for any other
asset we own yeah and it's true for
almost anything I mean now you know now
I I've had people call in and say you
know I have a diamond ring that was my
engagement ring that's worth $10,000
should I sell that no you can't get
another one of those there's only one
can you get another truck oh crap
they're on every corner you get on the
truck when you're not broke now can you
do this without that okay here's what it
takes all right
$35,000 a year $3,000 a month for two
years which on $1 120,000 means you guys
are living on beans and rice rice and
beans you don't see the inside of a
restaurant you're not going on vacation
you're living on a tight budget you and
your husband are both so committed to
this that your fingernails are bleeding
you are fighting scratching clawing
taking every you sold so much stuff the
kids think they're next and you can pay
off $70,000 in two years and keep the
truck okay but you can't half butt do
any of those things and get there and
keep the truck so okay he's an All or
Nothing kind of guy so I just need to
get them all in right he's got to be all
in you cannot there's you cannot wander
out of $70,000 worth of debt you have to
go like so angry at the whole situation
that anybody that gets in my way is in
trouble you follow me I mean it's like
ah you know we're getting out and but
you're doing it together you're not
yelling at each other I don't mean that
we're yelling at the debt we're yelling
at the the former version of me that was
stupid okay I'm not going to do this
anymore and this is how I got out this
is how we've leted other people out over
the years so that's what you got to do
and it's almost as if the truck and you
could keep the truck if you do all the
other stuff I'm talking about that's
fine and and it doesn't violate our
rules actually but you were looking for
you know kind of a shortcut with the
Roth and no that one doesn't make sense
keeping the truck yeah 50/50 if you do
all the other stuff if you don't do all
the other stuff it's almost as if the
truck is in front of your husband as a
test mm to say all right we're going to
do all this other stuff and if it
doesn't work I'll even sell the truck
but let's try the other stuff first see
if we can keep the
truck but until he puts the truck on the
table as an offering puts it on the
altar as an offering then um you know
that's a test of his commitment yeah
otherwise we know he's more committed to
driving that truck than he is being out
of thatt yeah our friend John Maxwell
probably stole this idea from night
Andale but he says it so well he says
what are you willing to give up to go up
and that's what you were saying and you
know at this point it's like do I care
more about how the truck makes me feel
or do I care more about how the debt
makes me feel and that's the thing about
this you know when people say stuff they
tell us when we meet them and they've
gone through financial pece University
and they've paid off you know $70,000
worth of debt in two years they say you
changed my life I didn't change their
life they changed their life but Ramsay
didn't change their life they changed
their life Ken didn't change their life
that's correct when they when they say
you you know you changed my career in
order to go through the transformational
process to get out of the
transformational process to get a
different career you have to go through
transformation that's right and that's
it's it's not the 70,000 that's going to
completely set you up for winning it's
who you become the other side of it
that's correct yeah that's the thing
yeah and so when you you know the person
you have the the couple the quality of
relationship the um the the respect you
have for each other that you have to go
through to get to the other side of this
is is the real treasure it's not the
debt free that's correct and and it will
cause you to go on to build wealth it'll
cause you to raise better kids it'll
cause you everything because it makes
you to into a much stronger couple
stronger as individuals confident
competent you know you have to transform
be not conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey person ality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at
5225 Dustin is in Columbus Ohio hi
Dustin welcome to the Ramsey show thank
you for having me sure what's
up um so me and my wife we currently 25
um we have just taken in the uh some
student loans that we're kind of like
feeling a little uneasy about that is
just now hitting about
$60,000 uh in student loans as we you
just took them in what does that mean
it's not a stray dog how what are you
talking about like we from Biden's plan
that he had originally had so we're just
now getting to them about the debt loan
forgiveness all that stuff so now that
it's finally coming in we're like oh we
have $60,000 in student loan debt okay
you always had
it yeah we were not paying on it if for
three years yeah okay I got we not pay
so now it's coming now it's coming down
on you okay I got you all right I'm with
you yep correct um as well as we have
$50,000 in auto loans so now as well as
we just had a a kid y now we're kind of
sitting back yep y what's your household
income
sir uh we each make about $80,000 a year
so 160,000 a year all right and you have
$110,000 in debt correct and you just
had a baby is the baby okay oh yep he's
healthy as can be wonderful okay so you
guys um are going to get to spend a lot
of time with a baby you're not going
anywhere all you're going to do is work
and be with a kid because you're going
to live on nothing and pay this off in
months okay tell me about the cars the
50,000 in car
debt um so she was a travel nurse about
a couple year like probably two years
ago so we were making a good bit of
money and we both decided to go get new
vehicles and then decided that we wanted
to have a kid so she stopped traveling
and got a better nurse job so what do
you owe what are the two cars you owe
50k break them down we have we have a
Ford F-150 larett we owe about 23,000 on
and then a 2019 Jeep Grand Cherokee that
we owe about 27,000 on okay you upside
down or you got any equity in them
uh the Ford uh I could probably get
about 30 out of it uh and then the Jeep
U probably out of what we owe I'll tell
you my friend I'm guessing the F-150 is
yours right it is well since Dave
disestablished you're not going anywhere
you don't need an F-150 that's super you
know Juiced up I'd sell that F-150 today
what's your car payment what's your car
payment on that about 481 we bought them
when interest rates were really low yeah
but that's a 4 $81 raise by being a big
boy and selling that
truck okay do I get another vehicle
$7,000 one go get you a $7,000
car okay you have a baby you're a
man yeah you have a family to take care
of yeah so um now here here's the thing
here's the thing
$160,000
income $110,000 worth of debt the
difference is
50,000 so not counting taxes which we
have to
count if you lived on 50,000 you'd be
debt free in one
year but you guys have been spending
like you're in
Congress yeah and the student loan thing
is your wakeup call to live on beans and
rice rice and beans ramen noodles never
go out to eat never go on vacation and
possibly sell your truck so that you can
get out of debt in one to one and a half
years okay now we have 27,000 in savings
do like to that'll make it go
faster that'll make it go faster pay off
and then just have nothing in like
that's where I like a p of savings so it
hurts me to spend it so I don't well it
didn't hurt you to go $50,000 in car
debt that's when you spent it you
already spent it you just hadn't
admitted it
yet yeah are you familiar with our baby
steps uh I am I haven't started it I've
just been listening on it off for about
a year and baby about the vehicle well
it's okay but get over the guilt and fix
it so baby step one is
$1,000 so that gives you 26 1,000 in
your savings account as an emergency
fund now you got
26 you guys can knock out that jeep
Cheroke list your debts smallest to
largest how many different student loans
are
there uh there's two only two what what
size are they uh they're each 30,000 a
piece okay so that's the two that's the
big one so when you list your debts
smallest to largest it goes 23 27 3030
you follow me y we're going to pay
minimum payments on everything but the
little one and attack the little one so
we're going to pay off her car
tonight and then you're going to decide
if you're going to keep your car if
you're going to keep it you're going to
start paying on it like a crazy man like
I'm talking you're gonna set
aside $8,000 a month for
debt okay and when you pay $8,000 a
month on 27 it goes away pretty quick
$88,000 a month on 30 it goes away
pretty quick oh and by the way you don't
have any car payments anymore so it
makes it easier to come up with
$88,000 okay $88,000 a month is $100,000
a
year okay and that that makes you debt
free in a year
okay but you're but you to do that you
understand you have to have no
life yeah yeah but that's okay for one
year you can do that you're young and
you're going to clean up your mess and
you have a new baby and you have an
incredibly bright future you have great
careers that's it
yeah okay now we and I should sell my
truck not pay my truck either one I
don't care but I think you need to cons
I think it would be a good emotional and
spiritual exercise for you and your wife
to discuss selling your truck tonight
after you pay hers
off okay buy a cheaper one yeah well you
you can decide you know cuz here's the
only thing it does it cuts down the
amount of time you have to live on
absolutely nothing and have no
life okay which right now is about a
year okay now as soon as you have no
debt at all then you're going to build
your emergency fund up and have that
Comfort again of 3 to 6 months of
expenses set aside that's your baby step
three we're going to help you with all
this cuz I've been right where you are
Dustin where I I've done stupid things
and I had a baby and I didn't know what
to do and there wasn't anybody to help
me and tell me and we're here to help
you so we're we're talking real straight
to you and telling you the truth cuz we
love you but that but we're here to help
you so we're going to put you guys into
Financial Peace University and we're
going to pay for it okay and you guys
it's a gift to your baby you're going to
change your whole family tree young man
but you too as adults now are going to
throw your shoulders back and quit
buying everything in sight like your
spoiled kids and be adults adults devise
a plan and follow it children do what
feels good yep and so you're not going
to do what feels good you're going to do
what right what's smart for the future
so the 30 and 40 and 50 year old version
of you two looks back and says wow see
Dustin the year I file bankruptcy I was
28 years old Rachel was
born and from then on I've never
borrowed another dime from then on I've
tithed at my church every single week
one tenth of my income from then on I've
been on a budget for the rest of my life
from then on I don't buy anything unless
I pay cash for it from then on because I
said never again and the the negative
thing was I lost everything I owned the
good news was it completely changed my
life and you got the opportunity to do
it without losing everything it's called
growing up and we all get to do it some
people do it at 52 some do it at 22 my
case it was 28 with the second kid
coming the year I file bankruptcy so you
don't have to do that you don't have to
be as dumb as I was we'll help you dude
we'll help you you got this you can do
it and by the way the Straight Talk at
dinner tonight when we talk about the
cars is I'd float the idea of her doing
a few nights or weekends with that
nursing background while you're watching
baby cuz you're not going anywhere
anyway and all of a sudden we've
increased our income to fast forward
what Dave has already laid out so we can
beat this in a year but it is going to
take big boy pants and big girl pants
sacrifice sacrifice sacrifice your
lifestyle lay your lifestyle down and
just put it just shoot it just just
shoot it live like a college student
this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
hey Dr John delone here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and hallow makes it easy to start a
daily practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
Hall makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hall.com ramsy today to
get three months of hallow for free
that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly has 19
service Brands Nationwide and a network
of local service pros Molly made Mr rder
plumbing and five-star painting just to
name a few visit neighbor.com to find
available service providers near you our
question today comes from Corey in
Tennessee I've been a v a vocational
instructor at my current job for 20
years they aren't interested in learning
anything on any level the students are
very disrespectful the bad behavior is
encouraged by decision makers I have
also worked at my church with young
people for 19 plus years and I'm
honestly burned out on kids I need to
work but I don't have much debt but I do
have some I just don't want to earn pay
being disrespected on a daily basis and
seeing the toxic Behavior encouraged the
state of Tennessee uh my job in the
state of Tennessee uh requires
retirement at 25 years uh excuse me I
messed that up it the my state of
Tennessee job for retirement is 25 years
at 55 years of age or 30 years of
service I only be 49 if I stay for 30
years so I don't know how that will pay
out I think I can do better and start
making more money I'm con cons currently
thinking about pursuing CDLs to start a
driving career what do you think should
I quit my job I couldn't even get
through it because you need to leave my
man um now don't leave without moving
into something but there's no question
you're not in an environment that you
have any control over to actually change
uh when you when you put yourself in an
environment like this that is very
institutionalized and very systemic as
it relates to government leadership
you're not going to be able to change it
so quit banging your head against the
wall I love the idea of moving into
something else let's get qualified for
it and then let's move on because
financially you don't have the margin
and you've got debt you got to pay off
so let's stay in the role let's get a
couple part-time gigs if you can do it
if nothing else just to get some relief
from this current day job that's just
beating the snot out of you yeah but
let's move on to something else and as
quickly as
possible so um quit working with youth
as the church today yeah that's easy
that's a non that's a no-brainer uh they
don't need you cuz you don't like it and
they can tell yeah and so could the kids
right yeah so it's good for the kids for
you to quit it's good for you to quit so
that that's one incremental thing it
sounds like you actually like teaching
mhm so I don't know where CDL came from
that sounds like something flew in
Midnight cable TV or something I don't
know that just sounds bizarre you know
what it is it's like sitting behind AE
that's right I don't have to talk to
young people I don't have to talk talk
to anybody yeah and I'm in a big truck
so nobody can make me mad you know I
mean oh my God no I don't think that's
um I don't think that's a career choice
I think that's just your running away
sure and so
um yeah I I think you need to go take
Ken Coleman's career assessment and
figure out I it's like $20 or $30 at our
website at Ramsey Solutions okay figure
out some things you need to do and then
you need to you don't need to run from
something you need to move to something
and the CDL is just you running from
something but you have
um you have five weeks to I'm making
this up to select something to start
moving towards and then I'm going to
give you four months to move towards it
so you need to be out of the church
teaching business by the end of the day
today and you need to be out of the
state teaching business by the end of
the year y y if you don't give yourself
some deadlines you'll bathe in the
sewage yes because you're comfortable
with what you know versus what you don't
know and I know and I think Dave you
make a very good point there there was a
season of life where you were excited
about being an instructor and a guide
and to the extent that you might be able
to move to another state agency where
you are in training um that is still the
heart of instruction of guiding people
and so look in you know where you've got
relationships because this is a
government job certainly kick the tires
on that as long as you're training
instructing I enjoy teaching you do
absolutely but I refuse at my at at
early in my career I refuse but I really
refuse now to be trying to teach someone
that's there against their will correct
so if someone wants me to come speak to
their organization and the people in
their organization are there against
their will I'm not willing to do that um
or I'm not willing to go speak to a
bunch of people that vinant disagree
with me and my job is to be there to
piss everybody off no thank you I've got
other things to do I'm there I want to
talk to people that I can actually help
that's right and move the needle for so
you know that that's just human nature
you don't want to wait bang your head
against the wall it's just silly so yeah
you you need to be teaching probably I
think you'll find that after you take
the assessment y i I think he'll
probably see the result of influence
which is very people focused work and uh
probably see communication there uh
instruction you'll see those themes so
uh go get that Ramy solutions.com it's
to get clear assessment and uh for
anybody thinking about that how do I
take those results and put it into a
realtime job very simple you take that
purpose statement which is a wonderful
gift that we give you there as a result
of all of your other detailed reports
and you begin to say this is what a job
description looks like where I am on
purpose I am there doing something that
makes a lot of sense to me because I'm
good at it I enjoy it and the results
fire me up that's what you're looking
for and in this case he wants to engage
with humans who want to learn something
in order to be able to do something I've
got a friend that was a classroom
teacher and got burn up burn out and
beat up and was done with it and um so
she went on to another career and and
you know some corporate training and
things where she actually enjoyed it but
instead of doing the ministry thing at
at church she is teaching um the uh us
um citizenship course oh fantastic and
it she say is the most inspiring oh I'm
sure and I mean these people know more
about American history than we do sadly
uh these folks trying to become citizens
and uh man it's she said there English
is you second language almost the same
course you know you're teaching that way
Oh my he she said it's just she's so
excited to go down and and by the way
they don't even pay her she goes for
free wow you know it's just incredible
so yeah that's a side thing our ministry
thing and um so yeah if you get in the
right situation where people are begging
to learn oh and you're a teacher oh it's
just about the most fun you can ever
have it's just chocolate chip cookie
straight out of the oven Man true it
reminds me of the first time Stacy and I
taught Financial Peace we were in
Atlanta and we had several young couples
we were all working with and they were
struggling they said hey you know this
Dave Ramsey guy and say she's like yeah
I worked for him and they said will you
teach us and we were like of course and
so we put a class together and the first
week we walked in the room and we could
see the light in their eyes they were
like help us sitting on the edge of
their seat and that and we didn't even
teach we we just pressed play on the on
the tape and you did the teaching but
that's the opposite of Cory he he's not
got people sitting on the edge of their
seat unless they're trying to leave the
room that's right yeah crazy that's
tough stuff tough stuff that is very
hard but very good advice by the way in
pivoting right to okay wait a second I
love instructing and so it's not
instruction I need to get rid of it is
changing my environment where I'm
instructing and who I'm instructing but
I learned this from you listening to you
coach on the Coleman show um it's an
amazing number of times that someone
thinks they hate what they do and they
because they've confused what they hate
where they do it and who they do it with
yeah they're doing the right thing in
the wrong
place yeah Absol oh for sure toxic
people toxic environment toxic culture
but doing the right thing and then they
go well I'm burned out on teaching no
you're not not all you're burned out on
hanging out with stupid people that's
right well you know Dave I shared this
yesterday uh on the show uh we have a
shortage of teachers Public School
teachers in America this is a big-time
problem and the reason is is because the
environment has gotten so awful that
these teachers who signed up to instruct
to guide the future generation they're
walking away well they don't want to
deal with all the woke stuff they they
want to teach history that's right I
don't want to teach gender reform I
don't want to get screamed at when they
give a kid a bad grade because the
parent can't handle it yeah and a lot of
junk going teachers unions no no help
that's correct and the helicopter
parents are coming in and I don't know
Ken did you know this did you know where
snowflakes come from no
helicopters think about it folks it'll
come to you that's good this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netw Suite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netw week worked for ramsy and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34,000
customers who Trust netsu to help make
them smarter and make better decisions
and level up their operations to learn
more get a free product tour at nets.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Jake is with us in
Nashville hi Jake how are
you hey guys thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it sure what's up well I'm
going through a major midlife crisis and
so I hope you guys don't beat up on me
too bad how old are you I'm 35
okay tell us about it yeah so I I want
to hit a reset button kind of on my life
um with what I do for a living and also
where I live um I guess before I dive
into that um let me give you just a
quick overview of our finances um so we
have a good budget I'm married I have
three kids we're in a suburb of
Nashville um we've got our emergency
fund of six months uh we got low living
expenses we got about 32,000
401K um I make about 130,000 salary and
then um last couple years I started
doing side hustling and I ramp that up
to about 120,000 a year uh doing HTML
development uh it's kind of a niche and
high demand do doing what HTML oh yeah
okay good okay yeah and uh we ow about
100,000 on our home it's worth about
600,000 we've been pretty aggressively
kind trying to pay it down it's 2%
interest rate and um we prepaid it two
and a half years just to give us a
buffer so we don't owe anything on it
till uh March
2026 um we have a $100,000 heok loan um
that we use to buy a second piece of
property out in McMinville which you
guys might know that area okay I'll
catch up with you in a minute on the
rest of it what's your
question yeah so my two questions are um
so so basically I'm doing work that I
just don't like doing anymore your day
job or the
HTML uh it's the same the side hustle is
the same um so it's you don't like
programming anymore no I I I was raised
on construction I got a blue collar
heart you know I love being outdoors
love the sun love getting concrete and
paint on me so what would you reset to
you said you're considering a reset what
would that reset look like workwise you
know so I've been doing this for 10
years years and so I don't even know yet
I I'd love to do something
entrepreneurial or um or something more
blue color you just told us what you
want to do I think you got a couple of
ideas but you're either looking for
permission or confirmation one of the
two maybe both so what are you thinking
about what are you really thinking about
I guess it's just hard to leave a good
income what are you thinking about doing
blue collar with your hands what do you
want to do I'd love to do landscape
design I'd love to do landscape
architecture but it's not a high-paying
career field but oh my goodness that's
not
true I guess when you start at the
bottom of the totem pole you're not
going to make anything right but who
says you have to start at the bottom of
the totem pole I'm talking to a guy I
wasn't doing I was doing landscaping
yeah but you're making 120 for yourself
in HTML so you can keep doing that while
you get the landscape thing going you
don't have to go down to nothing it's a
false narrative so do both sure you do
both now you have a full-time job plus a
job right yeah so just quit your day job
and go do landscape architect but dude
that you don't have to start making
$20,000 a year doing this that's
right I mean you've got all this life
experience so why don't you start poking
around about what it takes to be a
high-end landscape architect that makes
$250,000 a
year okay what's the process to do that
and I don't think it's a 15-year process
it's not you need to start hanging out
with some successful Landscape
Architects in Nashville and high some
high-end Builders and find out what
they're paying and what their customers
are paying Y what was their Journey how
long did it take them to get there see
you're operating in a vacuum right now
and when we operate in a vacuum of the
unknown we get terrified because we
don't have answers you got to go get
answers then you go oh I'm looking at a
fiveyear journey I'm looking at a
three-year Journey whatever it ends up
being I got to get this qualification
that's going to cost me this much it's
going to take me this long the great
news is you guys are in a pretty good
financial
situation and you can make this happen
Jake Ken and I have talked about this a
lot and I don't know what it is but it
seems to be human nature that people
when they uh you know you started into
programming at some point because you
enjoyed it when the joy started leaving
that and you were making good money the
there's an emotional handcuffs that
people automatically assume I don't know
why we do this but it's human nature
that the next job that if I'm doing a
job I love I must get paid less like you
must be punished for liking what you do
but that's not true you can make more
money ultimately doing what you love
I'll give you an example okay I was
buying and selling real estate again or
or helping people find foreclosure real
estate and making deals and after my
bankruptcy I'm 28 years old I was up to
30 years old 31 years old at that time
that's uh
1991 I was making $12,000 a year okay in
1991 doing that I felt like that God had
his hand on us to teach people how to
get out of debt live on a budget and
become wealthy and unbelievably generous
showing God's ways of handling money I
started putting together the pieces of
that and after a year of working on it
we figured out that we could quit our
doing real estate and work on financial
peace stuff fulltime but we would
probably only make 60,000 the first year
but we could see how we could make
millions so first year I made
62,000 the next year I made 140,000 the
next year I made 240,000 and I've never
looked back so it doesn't you may have
to take a temporary step back but this
idea that you must make less throughout
your life to do to have joy is
ridiculous that's right simple questions
Jake what do I need to learn that's the
certification process that's also
sitting with successful Landscape
Architects to figure out what the
journey is now we've got some wisdom not
just knowledge that's what I need to
learn and then how do I get about doing
it what do I need to do what do I need
to learn what do I need to do when you
get the answers to those questions it's
not so scary and again you've got great
side income right now uh and and I want
you get rid of that helck by the way
let's get rid of that yeah and and and
work the the baby steps to do that turn
it into the snowball that is it and and
just move forward with confidence now
he's talking about moving as well and
you may want to move that's okay want to
some move to something cheap listen if
you take your day job of 120 and you get
rid of it and you move into a landscape
thing and you only make 60,000 the first
year yeah then the next year you make
120 and the next year you make 240 and
you quit the side gig that's a
three-year plan yeah and he'll be
thrilled and you know and you're not
stuck no and you yes you should do this
he absolutely should do it you got to
honor that by the way it's very
interesting Dave you and I have done
this uh different ways but you know he
I've never had somebody call in and go
I'm not sure and then when I push him
and you go what are you thinking about
then he spits it out he's been thinking
about it but it's again it's that
permission thing to say wait a second I
can change I can leave a job doing HTML
making really good money and I can go do
something that's completely different
blue collar to use his pH you don't have
permission to assume that you're going
to make less correct let's go get I
remove the permission for that you need
to assume you're going to make more
we've taken that away because you're
going to be good at it and you're going
to choose your clientele that has money
we're not doing landscape uh
architecture for poor people we're going
to do landscape architecture for rich
people who give us big juicy checks for
putting their bushes in the right place
on their house oh my God come on
seriously you can do this and and you
don't have to dig all the holes in order
to be gratified that's silly so you can
do this you can absolutely do this
Landscape Architects in an area like
Nashville and can do very very well
you're talking about you can be a solo
preneur or you can build a nice company
with all of the building and you know
real estate better than I do oh yeah you
do quite well around here very good well
I mean you take a commercial building
like this we paid the guy to do that GE
well tell you what that's serious man
here's something I would encourage
people with you feel stuck but you're
not stuck what happens is is you've
chosen to stay put because you're afraid
that something bad will happen if you
move forward or you don't believe that
something good will happen that's just
good oldfashioned fear and doubt Dave
and you're not stuck you've just said
I'd rather stay still than deal with
confronting those two false
narratives that's sh it's done boys and
girls this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsey Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsey Network app in your
favorite app store
[Music]
today live from the headquarters of RAM
Ramsey Solutions broadcasting from the
PODS moving and storage Studios it's the
ramsy show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America I'm Dave Ramsey
your host kid Coleman Ramsey personality
number one bestselling author of the
book paycheck to purpose and host of the
Ken Coleman show where he talks about
work and careers is my co-host open
phones atle 88
25225 email comes across this article
comes across our producer's desk and he
said we need to make a comment or two on
this the Bloomberg survey of a top of
1,000 of the top 10% of us earners turns
heads this week uh because a quarter of
the respondents all making 175,000 a
year identified as either very poor or
poor or getting by but things are tight
over half of those surveys dubbed the
regular rich said they worry about money
the objectively wealthy grappling with
being subjectively poor provides quite
the snapshot of this moment in American
history it captures how the increased
cost of everything from Cars to tuition
to groceries makes it harder to build
wealth how Rising Generations are
failing to attain their parents
Financial Security and how social media
impacts perception fueling lifestyle
comparisons while making the ultra
wealthy class more visible but even for
the comfortable the gold posts keep
moving there are always the Joneses to
keep up with take the latest trend on
super Yachts for instance don't have
your own submersible on board well
you're practically a peasant this is
gobbley cook this is nonsense the
objective wealthy grappling has pointed
out that the increased cost of
everything is the problem there's no
mention in here of rising credit card
debt there's no mention of what the
average car payment is this is
highlighting we have more and more
people who just aren't willing to be
patient I like to get behind the problem
of the problem of the problem and this
is just highlighting that people are
griping about making
$175,000 a year inflation sucks Dave I
got two teenage boys and yeah my grocery
Bill's gone up to feed those guys they
eat a lot of food but I have margin and
if I don't have margin I can make margin
this kind of stuff makes me so angry
Dave
onomics inside my household M Trump's
Biden omics of course outside my
household I like that I can control
what's inside my walls enough to where
if Biden screws up the economy hint hint
then I can still be okay hint hint right
yeah so no we're not going to increase
the increased cost of everything did not
make $175,000 people feel poor yes um
you know what made them poor was $1
trillion in credit card debt $1.3
trillion in car debt and $1.7
trillion in student loan Deb is all of
those with a t
trillion count that with me boys and
girls that's a lot so yeah they're
they're so far in debt they can't
breathe and then yes they're comparing
themselves to uh to the to people on
social media and comparison is Rachel
Cruz says this is a great line yep and
her her book love your love your life
not theirs comparison is the thief of
Joy that's
right and that's what we're talking
about here that's exactly right so
social media made
these rich whiny brats yeah who can't
seem to manage the person in their
mirror comparing themselves on Instagram
to other Rich whiny brats be sizzle real
best of picture is uh causing them to
feel like they don't have any money yeah
that's what it is oh yeah so getting by
on
$175,000 a year it's a case study every
day on the show we help people get
through that the book baby STS
millionaires where we talk about all the
people that became millionaires one of
the things I point had to point out in
that book because we run into it so much
I did an entire chapter on this a
million doll net worth is not a
billion no a million is not a billi ion
so let me help you with this
billionaires have private jets
millionaires do not billionaires have
four houses millionaires have
one billionaires have seven cars
including a Lamborghini millionaires
have a used pickup
yep that's correct okay so people think
well when I get to a million dollars I'm
going to be flying private like somebody
on an MTV thing mhm right is MTV even
still open and
is is it still on the it's still on the
air on the air it's on the air but I
doubt there's much music on there's four
people on it now it's kind of gone the
way of CMT it just buried itself yeah
okay but anyway they um yeah so anyway
you know when you see the rich and the
glamorous and the famous what you're
seeing are
billionaires not Millionaires and so to
compare yourself as a millionaire which
is wealthy there's only about 14 million
millionaires in the United States that's
all mhm and so compare yourself with a
billionaire as a millionaire and thereby
declare yourself feeling poor well it's
it's you know of course so that
comparison is the thief of Joy you're
right Ken you're exactly right I mean
the opening of this article and and this
is this is we got to pay attention to
this folks because this kind of stuff
right here that oh I don't feel like
I've got much money when I'm making
$175,000 the problem is is your feelings
you felt you needed a car that you can't
afford you felt you needed to go to a
college that you couldn't afford you
felt a lot of things and let me tell you
where this goes Dave and I people told
you your feeling mattered right it
doesn't matter and and so uh here's
where this goes this is a kind of
garbage these articles are popping up
more and more this is where Universal
income starts to get a hold pay
attention to this stuff just watch for
it folks because when I can't take care
of my bills then I need someone to come
rescue me and you got a bunch of people
going I can't afford my bills bail me
out bail me out bail me out and this
this stuff is Insidious for younger
Generations that's the thing we got to
keep our eyes out for I'm telling you
right now we're seeing it tested several
Mayors in very left-leaning cities are
testing Universal income right now and
it's all because people don't want to
have to deal with their own feelings and
the mess they made forsel so they just
go take care of it for me let me tell
you watch for it personal finance is not
a feeling it's a MTH thing that's
correct and so here's a here's a feeling
for you if you don't have the money
don't buy it see that's not a
feeling that's a principle yeah it's
maturity and I but I want it that's a
feeling but I'm going to throw a fit
like a spoiled three-year-old on the
cereal owl that's a child it's a child
and I deserve it you don't deserve
anything you haven't earned the money to
pay for it come on you know don't tell
mean you deserve something you don't
deserve anything shut up call the
wambulance seriously if you if you
deserved it you could work and save up
the money and pay for it then we can say
you deserve it so people say DAV you
need to quit saying better than I
deserve better than I deserve is not a
statement of contentment that's a
spiritual statement I deserve hell and
I'm not going because of Jesus that's
better than I deserve better than I
deserve is a statement of spiritual
Grace it's not that I don't deserve the
success uccess I deserve the success
I've worked my butt off for 40 years at
this and now I'm an overnight success
operating word
work it don't even have to for the last
two decades but did it anyway hello this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
hey guys if you're enjoying the show you
can help us by subscribing clicking the
Subscribe button the follow button
leaving a five-star review click the
share button click the like button share
a link tell somebody where you're
listening spread the word for us boys
and girls it helps we really would
appreciate apprciate it we know that is
happening because we keep showing up in
the top 10 or 12 of all podcasts in the
entire world now with
1.5 billion
downloads thank you thank you very very
much we appreciate you we appreciate the
number of you listening on talk radio
and all the other venues that are out
there we appreciate you open phones at
tri8 825 5225 Katherine is in Washington
DC hi Katherine how are you I'm doing
well how are you guys doing better than
we deserve what's
up um I'm calling in today to um just
get your advice on our student loan
situation so um my fan and I we have
about I think
$55,000 in student loan debt and um we
paid that down significantly we had over
100,000 but um we just um purchased a
house and we had been saving you know
towards that goal and we're just kind of
reframing things now we had saved enough
to put 20% down um and get ourselves
sort of in better position um you know
with no PMI um but we bought at just the
wrong time it was right when the
interest rates went from like 5% to 7%
and so we're paying about $400 more than
we had planned to a month um on our
mortgage so we do have savings left over
um from what we had sort of been saving
up and and it's just just sort of a
question of like do we dump that money
straight into the student loans um or do
we do have some work that needs to be
done on the house and we're just trying
to figure out like what's the best
course of action moving forward when are
you getting
married um well we kind of put
everything on hold because of you know
saving for the house and and didn't want
to
that uh just like the the plan for the
wedding okay cuz there's not a we until
you're married we don't have a student
loan you got a student loan he's got a
student
loan you have a partnership on a house
with no partnership agreement which is
really unbelievably
dangerous uh you've gotten yourself into
some real scary territory here so you've
combined everything and you have no
method for managing it because you're
not legally combined does that make
sense it does he dies you're screwed we
didn't really have the right to get
married for a while it's my partner's a
woman so you know we've been together 17
years and I feel pretty comfortable with
that but you know that's I hear you okay
it's just you you need a detail if
you're not going to get married you need
a detailed partnership
agreement yeah we do have um we do have
some in place which is which is great
because I don't want one of you dying
and the other one being left in a mess
yeah yeah no I hear you I hear you we
try so how much is in savings how much
is in savings um so we have $25,000 in
savings and you have $55,000 in student
loan debt yes and what's your household
income um about 120 okay so if we throw
25 at the student loan debt that leaves
us 30 in student loan debt how quickly
does it go away making
130 yeah it goes It goes a little bit
more quickly um we I'm asking you
literally how fast do you pay it off
making 130 you only owe 30,000 is that
your only debt other than the house that
is our only debt yep yep we don't have
any car payments we don't have you know
we we try to make some smart decisions
there if you guys will commit to leaning
into this and knocking off that other 30
really fast I'd throw the 25 at it
today yeah I guess I just was nervous
because we you know our mortgage is just
more than we had initially intended just
because of the interest rate so we are
is so much that you have to use savings
to supplement it you need to sell the
house we don't we then use the savings
and get your student loan
debt okay you don't need the the nerves
are if you need to use your pay savings
to cover your mortgage you need to sell
the house if the nerves are that bad
otherwise you need to not have the
nerves and let's get this
done right right yeah yeah yeah that's
what I would do I would throw the 25,000
at it or I'd sell the house one of the
two but I don't think you're going to
sell the house so let's throw the 25 at
it and let's take the 30,000 and get it
knocked out you know in under a year put
$3,000 a month on it and be done in 10
months that's the way we look at things
around here hope that helps you thanks
for calling in Williams Withers in
Ontario Canada hi William how are you
great how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up good to hear uh my
wife and I are 27 and we'd really like
to do more farming um access to land is
obviously a huge hurt
so um my mom is set to inherit 100 acres
in it probably could be 10 or 20 years
we don't know um but since my dad passed
away last year she's been kind of just
crop sharing it with neor or with my
uncles and we're wondering if it makes
sense for us to um kind of do a renting
situation from her um that's what your
uncles are doing they're renting it on a
crop share basis right
yeah but we want to do a different type
of farming where we would um like be
putting a lot more fencing in planting
trees and ponds and that kind of thing
and if we and we would want to live on
site to do that um so there's a
farmhouse there so my mom's open to
doing that but we're worried that we
wouldn't have any ownership yeah I would
be too yeah you don't go greatly improve
the property when you're the
tenant right so like it's the land is so
hard so it seems like there's all this
land that we could use but it's so far
away in terms
of in terms of
what we could inherit it like after okay
what's this 100 acres
worth try again you broke up about two M
million or so okay let me help you with
us when you're 27 years old and you're
broke you don't get to buy a $2 million
business
no we were thinking of just um like
buying a smaller parcel somewhere else
that wouldn't be attached to my mom's at
all and wondering if that's a better way
to do it how many brothers and sisters
have you got one brother okay why don't
we go ahead and work out the estate plan
and your mom deed you part of
this already Okay and she own it now no
no so my grandmother still owns it so my
mom won't inherit it for now 10 or 15 oh
yeah so okay so this property is just
this property is not it's off limits
yeah for now unless your grandmother
wants to give it to
you but your uncles are farming it so
she's not going to give it to you she's
going to give wait a minute it's 100
acres and your uncles and your mom so
why is your mom getting all of it in 20
years or 100 is just her portion yeah
there's 400 total oh okay okay that
makes sense all right yeah
okay that's not going to solve your
equation okay that that's off limits 20
year waiting 20 years to do something
and fencing and putting ponds on
property that's not yours is insanity
too many things can go wrong with this
no so if you want to go farm what are
you going to do you're going to go lease
some land somewhere and
farm okay that's what you're you're
going to do what your uncles are
doing yeah and like we're worried about
that as well terms of improv improving
the land while it's only a
lease that's why we're just thinking
like so you recommend we just keep
saving up until we can buy our own land
that we can improve ourselves yeah don't
improve anything but if you want to be
in the farming business right now you
can be in the non-improving someone
else's land farming business okay until
you can get to where you can buy some
land and then you improve your own land
but I'm there's not a model that we can
recommend that you go spend $500,000 in
five years of your life and lots of
calluses and sweat to improve someone
else's property and then they end up
with all that no that's not a good plan
and there's not a there's not a
mechanism that protects you from that
just cuz you have the love and the
Romanticism about Farming Farming is an
incredible career but don't do it in a
stupid way because like any career done
stupid it's not fun this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
oh
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host Marie is with us on the debt
free stage right here in the lobby of
ramsy solutions hi Marie how are you I'm
good how are you better than I deserve
where do you live Ottawa Canada whoa all
the way from Canada to Nashville to do a
debt-free scream well congratulations
how much have you paid off uh
$132,600 42 excellent how long did that
take 46 months wow good for you and your
range of income during that four years
um it started at
59,0 uh 63 and uh last year it was
54550 and this year is going to be less
unfortunately okay why's your income
going down um I had started with uh
income replacement um with fetch Affairs
and uh when that ended I was still sick
with coid um and so I got a part-time
job and I was just laid off last month
so oh wow okay all right cool so right
now you're unemployed yes and you paid
off
$133,000 making basically $55 $60,000 a
year yeah what kind of debt was the
133 um it was cell phone therapy
overdraft personal loan o um School uh
government loan credit cards uh
retirement loan for school which is
allowed in Canada um and a student line
of credit wow I also cash flowed Windows
uh electricity and fertility treatments
during that time you were kind of normal
I mean you got dead on everything y so
what happened to you four years ago that
got you started all this ramsy stuff um
so I had uh my mom had sold our
childhood home and uh moved to Ottawa
with me because I was going to be a
midwife and on call
24/7 and she said that I could live
Grant fee rentree as long as I was
paying off my debt MH um and then after
we moved we were doing Renos and we had
a whole bunch of chaos um so may 2019 is
when I really got serious about
it okay so your mom inspired this sort
of yeah yeah okay and then how did you
get connected to Ramsay um I'd actually
read your book uh Total Money Makeover
in 2008 and uh the only piece that I
took was uh baby step two so I had this
is my second time through but this one's
going to stick ah good but now you're
done I mean you're out of debt you're
done with that part anyway yeah yeah
yeah so you get to move forward you're
not going back in debt again no and I
listen to the podcast every day so ah
well thank you we're honored to have you
what was the toughest part of this
journey for
you
um I think just getting control of my
budget I am a spender with a surplus
mindset so um not spending is extremely
difficult and as a single person um with
a daughter and taking care of my mother
it's you know there's always things that
you want and think you need MH so that
that was the hardest part and when I
started the process I was in school and
when I finished the process I was back
in school so what are you studying um I
just finished uh cabinet making and
Furniture no technician on August 18th
so okay so you're ready to go to work
doing that huh yes very good proud of
you very cool sounds like you've been
through a lot of transformation yes been
been a wild four years yeah yeah yeah
wow well good for you congratulations
how's it feel to be completely free it
is amazing how old are you uh 44 have
you ever been debt free in your adult
life um yeah I actually um when I uh
transferred to the full-time military I
was debt-free uh I had uh been working
for 10 15 years um and then my income
almost tripled and I went
woohoo there are no
limits I am a spender okay I got you
okay so that's the fall off the wagon
Bart you don't want to do again no never
gotcha okay I'm with you well well done
okay four years 46 months you pay off
133,000 making $55,000 to 60 right
that's pretty impressive uh why do you
tell people the key to getting of
deadish um the biggest thing I think is
um never giving up um I mean no matter
how slowly you're moving forward you're
moving forward and uh no matter how long
it took me I knew that it was going to
end yeah way to go way to go I'm proud
of you thank you good work I bet your
mom's proud of you yes yeah this is
something she likes for you she's happy
for you yeah that's good good for you
well played well played well played
excellent excellent work all right and
you brought your daughter with you right
yes and how old is she she is seven oh
okay and what is her name Cecilia ah
very good all right we've got a copy of
the baby steps millionaires book because
you are on your way to do that and of
course a Total Money Makeover book as
well and a financial peace uh University
uh membership for you to sign up all of
that is the live and give bundle you'll
live some of it you'll give some of it
we're so proud of you guys well done
thank you very very well done all right
it's Marie and Cecilia from Canada
$133,000 paid off in 46 months making 59
to 54 count it down let's hear a
debt-free Scream 3 2 1 I'm dead
free
[Applause]
yeah well done well done oh man that was
excellent great job kiddo very cool
Margo is in New Hampshire hey Margo
welcome to the Ramsey show thank you
very very much for taking my call sure
what's
up well my husband and I have term Life
policies for our life insurance and we
are 12 years in we've been paying 182 a
month and our situation from when we
entered into this to now is very
different so we're just wondering if we
should stop paying and pay out now
MH well term life insurance is to
replace his income to make sure you're
okay if he
dies yes so he is retiring within a year
no but are you okay if he
dies emotionally no no I'm not talking
about that
financially financially uh yes so what's
your net
worth well
all in with our house our in um
retirement probably about six 1.6
million okay and um houses paid for yes
kids are grown and gone no kids okay so
if he does you got 1.6 million you got
to figure this out and you're how
old I am 53 okay I think you'll be fine
don't you I I think I'll be fine I think
uh we're both healthy and yeah we we try
to live a healthy same thing in Reverse
right if you die financially after he
quits crying he'll be okay
right yes yes he he'll be he'll be
better off quicker than I will okay but
I mean he's got 1.6 million too right
yes yeah yes and the house is worth how
much uh the house is
about at least 650
okay so if you got a million dollars and
if it generates 10% that's $100,000 a
year if it generates 8% or if it
generates 12 and you uh left four in
there for inflation then that would be a
gener you know you pulled off eight as
an example that'd be 80,000 so you can
live on 60 70 $80,000 a year right yes
we can uh we we have no debt I do have
two horses which is very expensive but
one of them is 25 so un fortunately I'll
have one at some point yeah can can you
live on 60 to 80 to $90,000 a year
absolutely okay then you're
self-insured and you don't need life
insurance unless you just want
it okay so
basically it's okay to not pay the rest
of the 18 years no and just take the
payout now well there's not a payout on
term life
insurance um well maybe it's not term
then because they they say that we do
get a a payout well then I definitely
would cancel that crap okay yeah it's
garbage Insurance then you've got whole
life life insurance you don't have term
okay yeah it sounded expensive so I'm
not surprised I don't know what the
coverage amount is but yeah think we got
your answer you're self-insured this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day James 1:22 do
not merely listen to the word and so
deceive yourselves do what it
says Vince Lombardi says it is time for
us all to stand and cheer for the Doer
the achiever the one who recognizes the
challenges and does something about it
yes there we go it's almost like the man
in the arena right there it really is
stuff man well done well done hey guys
it's almost over the August cash
giveaway it's almost it'll end in just a
couple days here all month long we're
giving away cash you win one of our $500
weekly prizes or even the grand prize of
$3,000 to increase your chances enter
daily at ramseys solutions.com
giveaway you can also get our
bestselling books like The Total Money
Makeover Ken's number one bestseller
from paycheck to purpose and Dr John
delon's own your past change your future
his number one bestseller all of those
are only $12 right now and you can
pre-order Dr John delon's brand new book
building a non- aous life which comes
out October the 3 and guess what you'll
learn the six daily choices to break
free from a life spinning out of control
from a life of anxiety plus when you
pre-order a day for just $20 you'll get
$75 in free bonus items all the
questions from for humans conversation
cards are on sale for $12 all of this is
happening in the store at ramseys
solutions.com
sstore and of course to sign up for the
free money ramsy solutions.com giveaway
and there is no purchase necessary must
be
18 Max is in Missouri hi Max welcome to
the Ramsey Show hey how's it going guys
better than we deserve brother what's
up hey so my wife and I are currently in
baby step number two and I am a
self-employed flooring installer so we
kind of just need some advice
on on maybe the emergency fund or what
can we save for during winter time when
my slow my work gets kind of slow and
January February slow months and income
is lower what can we do or what advice
do you have so that when those months
come we can still be paying off
debt okay you're you're installing
floors in on the interior of
construction right correct like carpet
hardwood laminate so why does that stop
in the
winter and you usually just get slow
like I'll have a week or two and uh
every other day you know I won't have a
job or and kind of we're just nervous
on uh you know this coming next season
what what we can do to be prepared for
that okay have you got only one supplier
of jobs I mean one one vendor you work
for um mainly yes I work for one shop
but I also have a couple of couple
builders that you know keep me busy also
but uh yeah mainly I work through one
shop yeah this is not a I need more
savings problem this is a business
problem you need more business so you
don't have dead spots I want you to be
covered up and backlogged and people
waiting in line to get you to install
their
floors so you don't have these gaps they
shouldn't be gaps you should be covered
up all the time except when you don't
want to work because it's Christmas or
something yeah yeah you need more
sources and if you can't figure out the
sources which you should be able to you
should be working like a dog right now
to get that income on an average across
you have a couple of ways to do this but
more options is the answer here it's not
about savings and I also say I'll bet
you have some other trade skill that you
could bring to the table if for some
reason and again I don't think this is
the case but for some reason you weren't
able to get more flooring jobs um
there's some other skill sets that you
have where in the trade you should be
busier than you could possibly be yeah I
mean uh uh uh now I mean grass cutting
slows down in the winter but installing
carpet
inside in you know where things are like
warm and stuff it doesn't it it you know
building business doesn't stop in
November December January I'll tell you
an idea Max that I've got I got a good
friend friend who is running a business
in the Atlanta area Dave he just got
into it and it's these remediation
companies you know when there's a mold
media yeah there's a flood or something
has happened frozen pipes okay so they
come in and they do all the cleanup of
the water but they've got relationships
with contractors to come in and actually
do the fixing work he needs to be making
friends with with people that are in
that business saying hey you need a good
flooring contractor I'm your guy yeah
one of his frozen pipes in the winter
that's what I'm saying that' be your
back fill okay I'll go with that busy as
he can be right now yeah and he's
looking for good contractors that he can
rely on he's G griping at me on the golf
course I can't find good contractors
will'll come out and fix floors so I'm
just throwing that out there to Max
that's where we go get more opportunity
Daryl is in Phoenix hi Daryl welcome to
the ramsy show uh actually sure my name
is Darnell oh I misread it I apologize
Austin actually typed it in correct I
screwed up sorry Darnell what's up
that's okay sir um uh that's that's very
common um so um well first of all thank
you for having me Mr Ramsey uh and uh um
you know I actually met Dr John deloney
down in Dallas actually uh I I Reed of
uh tobacco and uh alcohol when I met him
but U he was at a book siding in the at
Barnes & Noles in Dallas but let me get
to my question so uh I'm trying to
figure out a way to help to my help my
sister um my sister um her car went
out uh she has a uh a car note on it is
she owes $122,000 on that car M uh she
also has student loan debt of
20,000 and her income is uh $3,200 a
month now her living expenses she lives
she lives with her mother uh we have
different moms but she lives with her
mother um uh uh her living expenses you
know you know housing and utilities is
600 a month food 400
clothing Personal Care $1100 M uh right
now she doesn't have transportation she
was sharing her mom's car but her mom's
car also went out now what's wrong with
the $112,000
car the engine seized
up she blew the
engine yes sir or at least that's what
it sounds like um oh wait a minute
sounds like so she's not taking it to a
mechanic no she she she did uh she told
me the the mechanic told her that the
engine seized up the thing is she she
lives in Alabama I live in Arizona she
lives in Alabama okay I mean I need to
know what seized up means cuz that you
mean she blew the engine is what it
sounds like okay so it's a major a major
repair you think yes sir uh she told she
gave me a quote of uh it's going to cost
her about eight $9,000 yeah now I came
up with I came up with three options uh
I got a I got a truck I can loan her I
ain't going to lie I'm G have to put
some money into it but you know I can
learn of the truck the only thing is the
truck got about 300,000 miles on it it's
it's old now it runs
though yes sir as opposed to her car
which doesn't run okay what's the second
option uh second option um it's going to
take me what it's going to take me like
I want to say about six months but you
know I can give her the money to uh uh
um put a new engine in in in her car
third
option uh um third option is she pauses
uh she's on baby step number two right
now
M uh she could pause the baby steps and
you know save money for a car right op
pressure fourth option is you loan her
your truck you guys all scratch some
money together and you buy a used engine
from a junkyard and you have H A Friend
down at the church do the engine
installation or an inexpensive mechanic
do the engine installation and we fix
this car for $3 to $4,000 not $8,000
$8,000 is either a brand new engine or a
rebuilt engine she can't afford that in
a $112,000
car yes sir you don't spend $8,000 on a
$112,000
car yes sir so loan loan her my truck
and scratch together the money to put an
engine in her car then take your truck
back a used engine in her car an engine
with 30,000 Mi on it in a car that total
that's sitting in the
junkyard and it'll be a tenth the not a
tenth but it'll be 25% of the cost and
that cuz you just don't put a brand new
engine in a 12,000 Mi car or $12,000 car
that's not doesn't make sense at all hey
man thanks for the call Ken Coleman good
show today thank you sir guys in the
booth great work the booth dudes pulling
off yet another great program I'm Dave
Ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
down daily with the Prince of Peace
Christ
Jesus hey it's Ken if you like what you
heard in this episode and want to know
more about getting started on the ramsy
baby steps go to ramsy solutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
again that's ramsy solutions.com and
click get
[Music]
started